ON THE SEASON TO START THE
SEASON.
HAS TIED NUMBER 1 OVERALL IN
THE NHL.  THE
DEVILS, YOUNGEST TEAM IN THE
HIT FROM VATRANO WILL SHOOT BLO
IN  WELLLENGE CERTAINLY
SIX AND HAVE TO GO
HIS STICK.
THAT ALLOWED THE
TRYING TO SPARK HIS
WEEGARARBUTTERED TOAST FROM ONE
GOAL
GREAT OPPORTUNITY FOR
PUT OUT IN FRONT, THEY SCORE!
GREAT EFFORT. IN FRONT
POSITIONING IN BEHIND AND HIS
1 PANTHERS
DUCLAIR SKILL TAKES
I BELIEVE BOTH SKATES
ARE ON THE BLUE LINE.
THIS GOAWAS ON SITE.
>>Steve: I
ASSIST.
THE POWER PLAY SHOOTING JUST
SN
FRONT BENNETT WITH A CHANCE AND
TO ME IT WAS A DUCLAIR'S NINTH
AGAIN GOLDIE, GOING BACK TO
TUESDAY'S GAME, PANTHERS
THREE GOALS IN A SURPRISE
STRONG, SPINSGIVE HIMSELF AN
OPPORTUNITY TO GET CONTROL OF T
NINE.
PLAYERS WEARING SPECIAL SHARANG
SAVES IN THIS
SHARANGOVICH, GUDA STEAL BYLINE
HUBERDEAU.
PANTHERS HAVE NOT MISS